we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in i like this one
take a listen to this this is david
calling from lake harmony is wondering
why the Trump administration still is
trying to get travel ban and stated
since it's been more than ninety days
since the original attempt to put it in
place and so they should be done their
research as to quote what the hell is
going on
thanks yeah this is a good point which
is this is a top priority right we're
going to shut down Muslim immigration
until we can figure out according to the
president what the hell is going on
haven't we had over a hundred days now
to figure out what the hell is going on
can trump come to us and say hey here's
what the hell is going on he's clearly
telling the Russians in the Oval Office
what the hell is going on with Isis
related Intel but what about telling the
American people what the hell is going
on with regard to the Muslim immigration
problem that he claims exists yeah that
was such a strange moment in American
history in December of 2015 when he made
that announcement because remember Trump
was reading something off of a paper as
if it was his big policy proposal yeah
and who wrote down the words until we
figure out what the hell is going on
that just doesn't sound like it would
work maybe he ad-libbed that part I
don't know but in any case we should
know by this point what the hell is
going on on the bonus show today number
one Mars astronauts may spend a year
orbiting the moon in training for the
eventual trip to Mars Tennessee is
making Community College free for all
adults with some stipulations but
they're pretty reasonable stipulations
and endless soda and potato chips at a
cardiology office what is that about I
will tell you on today's bonus show go
to david pakman.com slash membership to
sign up for membership that will give
you instant access to the bonus show you
can also make a pledge of any amount
even a dollar a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show